l'audi à gars termine son quart de nuit
à l'hôpital de gatineau
recruté en france en 2019 l'infirmière
jeu déjà quitté le québec où les
procédures pour la résidence permanente
prennent beaucoup de temps en gros on
peut dire du 3 ans d'attentes
après avoir travaillé un an déjà au
québec
elle va donc traverser la rivière pour
vivre et travailler à ottawa en ontario
l'ontario qui le reste du canada un
programme d'immigration fédéral qui
s'appelle entrée express tous les délais
sont entre express qui sont assurés pour
80% des candidatures s'est traité en six
mois six mois au lieu de deux ou trois
ans au québec c'est qu'ottawa a lancé un
programme accéléré d'obtention de la
résidence permanente qui vise entre
autres les infirmières séduisant pour
lydia qui perd soit une augmentation des
contraintes au québec depuis un an voire
au niveau du reste du canada mais il ya
des programmes qui sont faits pour
accélérer les choses et puis faciliter
l'accès à la résidence permanente épique
au québec on nous disait on va rendre
plus difficile plus long et plus
compliqué françois legault reconnaît des
lenteurs mais accuse ottawa de ce traîné
les pieds dans le traitement des
dossiers québécois vous l'avez vu
obtenir
toutes les approbations du fédéral ça
prend 27 mois alors que dans d'autres
provinces et six mois problème
potentiellement sérieux pour le québec
qui cherche désespérément des
infirmières comme anaïs méga embauché en
2019 par l'institut de cardiologie de
montréal la jeune française se débat
depuis deux ans pour régulariser son
statut c'est pas très compréhensible
sachant qu'en ce moment on manque des
personnels énormément dans les hôpitaux
et que ce serait tout à l'intérêt du
gouvernement québécois de décès nous
faciliter de rester la rétention des
infirmières qui immigrent au québec
restera un gros défi en raison de
l'explosion des besoins
le québec veut recruter 1700 infirmière
à l'étranger uniquement cette année ici
david gill radio canada montréal